the saying that this is overdue is an
understatement so let's get right into
it I did my top 10 stories for the 9th
doctor the 10th doctor I said it was
going to do the 11th but then things
happen in the new series of doctors
started I did that instead so this got
pushed off hein finally now getting to
it here are going to be my top 10
stories for the 11th doctor Matt Smith
still my own personal favorite doctor in
the interest of full disclosure and also
quick reminder on how I do this I count
two partners as a single story so with
that groundwork laid let's get right to
it
number 10 the girl who waited there's a
lot that I like about this episode and
I'm premise this should drive me crazy I
mean how often do we see actors trying
to play themselves older in old age
makeup and just become embarrassing but
first of all Amy
older Amy gets a very subtle makeup
treatment and she plays the aged up
fairly subtly it's incredibly believable
her performance is truly what makes this
episode because if I'm being honest
there are little things about it that
bug me I've complained about the hand
robots before there's also the fact that
Amy built on sonic screwdriver which I'm
not entirely sure that I buy but her
performance in this is so good and the
ending of it just you feel the weight of
the doctor shutting the door leaving her
out and then having this moment I'm not
just taking the burden on himself he
ends up sharing that burden with Rory
which is kind of a dick move but it just
makes the impact of what happens all the
more powerful so this is really case
where performance in the execution
nailed this thing to a tee
number 9 Amy's choice enough her Amy
centric episode go figure this is
another one that comes down largely to a
performance in this case though it's
Toby Jones is the dream Lord oh man do I
love him and I wish they could figure
out a way to bring him back he's just so
skeevy and mischievous and you want to
punch him in the face and he just revs
up the doctor in just the right way I'm
sort of bouncing between the two
different realities I think is played
well they choose good times to make
those changes they do a pretty good job
of emphasizing the danger in both of
them if you did spend too much time sort
of looking at them the the old people
it's a little goofy but again
does not have to be perfect to be great
and as I said the performance from Toby
Jones is what puts this up over the top
and as always very solid work for Matt
Smith Arthur Darvill and Karen Gillan
number 8 Vincent and the doctor this is
one that after the first time having
seen it I never would thought would make
a top 10 because I didn't think much of
it the first time because you know the
alien creatures it's fine there's
nothing wrong with it but it's not
particularly unique or original but I
didn't appreciate the first time I saw
this what this was actually about in
that it's about human connection it has
this wonderful message that just because
you don't save someone and ensure that
they have a happy ending to the Y
doesn't mean that you weren't important
to them and so when I watched it for a
second time
it just it bowled me over with just how
heartfelt the episode is and the
performance of the guy who plays Vincent
van Gogh is spot-on it's wonderful it's
heart-wrenching he looks terrific in the
part every now and then you get a Doctor
Who episode where the monsters the
aliens are not the point that's very
much the case here but for in order for
those episodes to work whatever is the
point needs to be pulled off really
really well and once I got my head in
the right wavelength for this episode
yeah it does it really well number seven
The Impossible Astronaut and the day of
the moon there's a lot that I really
like about this two-parter I mean first
of all I like River Song so I'm always
happy to see her back I love the very
idea of the silence I love the way that
they look and the sort of way that they
keep track on their bodies it's just
this wonderful creepy thing I mean I
said before for me I actually like the
silence and find them slightly creepier
than even the weeping angels that's
largely a personal preference but beyond
that I think what really hammered home
this episode and this story why I love
it is the end of day in the moon and the
solution that the doctor comes up with
splicing that footage of the silence
saying you should kill us all on sight
into the lunar landing footage oh it
when you realize what he's just did and
the triumphant music swells in yeah oh
that is such a fantastic moment and it
and it kept what could have otherwise
been a troublesome episode because
that's a lot left hanging at the end of
this story but it wrapped up
particular chunk of the series long
story that it was telling so well I was
perfectly happy to wait until later to
find out those other answers number six
the name of the doctor again I'm a bit
of a sucker forever song not going to
claim otherwise but beyond that this
episode really upped the great
intelligence in my mind in terms of how
good a returning villain he is because
up to this point few times we've seen
him he's had schemes that the doctor has
foiled at this point he only has one
goal destroy the doctor at as completely
as he possibly can and he wins he
succeeds and klar the sacrifice that
Clara makes to go in and fix his
timeline at basically assuming it's
going to be at the cost of her own life
I love the tension of this episode you
really feel with from Matt Smith's
performance just how nervous and scared
and just tightly wound about this entire
situation he is so I love that we get
vastra Jenny Strax there's a lot going
on it's episode and it all fits together
so well and then that ending with when
we got our first look at the war doctor
and go what is going on that Wow that's
a heck of a cliffhanger I would argue
possibly the best one doctor who has
ever had number five the asylum of the
Daleks this is just a rip-roaring good
time of an episode it's got some of my
favorite lines from Matt Smith don't be
fair to the Daleks when they're firing
me at a planet he's just at his quirky
fast-thinking best in this i love seeing
all the different Daleks so many them at
that point we hadn't seen before in a
very long time I thought the concept was
nicely creepy I really liked this
initial version of Clara I actually
liked it better than the one that we
ended up having as a full-time companion
but she was intriguing and fun fast
talky felt like a match for the doctor
and I was immediately kind of hooked in
like I liked her and the twist with her
at the end works for me very well
hinging so much of Amy and Rory's
relationship could have been a big sort
of just brick around the neck on this
episode but it's not because those two
actors are so good together they can
sell the problems
the relationship just as well as they
could sell the high points of that
relationship and the introduction of
sort of the the Dalek shells you know
the people and the thing comes out that
was really creepy I haven't liked the
use of those things since then but I try
not to hold that against this episode
this one just goes from the very
beginning and I love this ride
number four good man goes to war now
remember I said about the last one it
was just a real fun ride this one this
one is heavy and so much of that is in
Matt Smith's performance because when he
says to Madame Kovarian good men don't
need rules
this is not the day to find out why I
have so many you feel the Menace and the
threat in those words so well and also
to watch the episode like get triumphing
then get sad and then get hopeful again
at the end that's that's a wonderful
emotional rollercoaster and I love the
way it opens with Rory where is my wife
this was the point that Rory became a
genuine badass as far as I'm concerned
especially when it came to Amy is our
introduction to vastra and Strax and
Jenny and I like them so first
appearance bonus points there and that
reveal at the end about River Song and
her name and there are only rivers in
the forest and having that sink in and
the music the music is just so hopefully
it's coming from this low place of we
failed the bad guys one but then no no
wait and the music emphasizes that so
much I this is a wonderful episode and I
love the emotional journey of it number
three the doctor's wife here's an idea
that on paper sounds terrible this
should be absolutely awful the
consciousness of the TARDIS put into a
physical human form that the doctor can
interact with this should be the most
painful piece of crap ever and it's just
not between Neil Gaiman's writing and
with the performance that we get from
that woman I'm sorry I forget the
actresses name but in so many ways she
she matches Matt Smith's energy but it
and a slightly off wage it got kind of
in the way that he's slightly off but
they feel distinctly different doesn't
feel like she's imitating him and
way but they complement each other very
well and then houses surprisingly good
villain when it's nothing but a green
light and a voice but wonderful vocal
performance from Michael Sheen playing
that part and this is another one this
is just a fast paced fun ride I love all
the interactions this this is really one
of those ones where the interactions are
what make it watching these characters
bounce off of each other or in the case
of house tormenting other ones and you
know again the conclusion should work
with just basically watching lights
change but it feels right it feels
triumphant it feels earned this is this
is just one of those cases where it's a
wonky idea executed as best as it could
ever possibly be and I love it
we're getting down to it now number two
the day of the doctor is this one kind
of a cheese since is God more than just
the 11th doctor in it no I don't think
so I still consider it he's his story
it's during his tenure and even if it is
a cheat I don't care this is a great
episode this is another one a little bit
like Vincent and the doctor where
initially watching it I was kind of like
well this seems odd because we came into
this off of name of the doctor and I
thought all the focus was gonna be with
the war doctor really gonna dig into
that he's there and he's good but
there's so much time to spend with his
icons it took me a little while to be
like hold on how is this going but it's
about finding the better answers it's
about not having to do the thing the
horrible thing that you think you have
to and the Zygons story complements what
is going on on Gallifrey with the moment
and I love the moment I love Billy Piper
coming back to play the bad wolf entity
that that I love not only that
performance but I love retro actively
what it kind of does to the concept of
bad wolf as a whole
I love as good Kate Stewart is great in
this and then the end Tom Baker oh my
god that will never stop being amazing
and you know just Matt Smith again just
doing great work and it's interesting to
see him and tend get along actually
quite well they've got a few sticking
points but generally when the doctor
meets himself he tends to not get along
with himself but these two they jive
enough then yeah they kind of bounce off
and it's nice and it's fun especially if
you're familiar with other multi
dr. stories it's actually kind of nice
to see them getting along as well as
these to do and I came very close to
making this my number one choice
actually the one that ended up coming up
at number one surprised me because I got
to tell you guys I had a hard time
ordering this list I narrowed it down to
my top ten without too much issue but
trying to come up with an order drove me
crazy and I am honestly I'm kind of
surprised of what's my number one but if
I stop and think about it yeah yeah
that's my favorite and that is the 11th
hour the very first time we ever got a
full episode with Matt Smith as the
doctor it just does everything a new
doctor story should it establishes him
his personality but he's he's still
figuring himself out and yet having seen
enough of him later on we see I was able
to go back and pick out and I was like
ya know there's all the pieces and he's
still forming them together but oh god
that that moment at the end were again
the music the music during Matt Smith's
10 year was phenomenal I mean the music
and doctor who has been great since it
has come back but that music especially
the hello I'm the doctor music where he
walks through the hologram and there he
is bowtie just looking ridiculous but
looking perfect and seeing him just
trying to to work the problem but he's
not all there and we know he's on there
in the introduction to Amy and I love
the whole concept of Amy I love someone
who has an immediate deep connection to
the doctor but also an immediate
skepticism of him because he left her he
left her for years and then did it again
is it a perfect episode no the atraxi
eyeball aliens little goofy Prisoner
Zero is effective and creepy but not a
lot of depth to him but you know what it
doesn't matter because if I am being
honest with myself this just feels so
right as the one I've gone back and
watched the most it's the one I have the
most fun rewatching it is my favorite
eleventh Doctor story what about you
though how many people are just pulling
their hair out either by my things that
I've omitted or the order that I put
these things in whatever you're feeling
or if you want to give
your own top ten drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned